[Music]
[Applause]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to freddy fazbear's pizzeria
simulator now this is scott coffin's
latest
and greatest game in the five nights at
freddy's franchise but
i don't want you to be suspicious i
don't want you to look any deeper
i'm sure this game is exactly as it
seems
it's a simple pizza tycoon game
where all you have to do is design your
pizza
and feed it to the hungry boys and girls
that come by
to your establishment so let's get to it
shall we
when i want a pizza i like a great
pepperoni
and olives pizza so i'm gonna go with
that one let's go to the pizzeria shall
we
oh yeah all right ah
[Music]
oh
all right well you hungry kids you go
this shirt
this certainly doesn't seem like an
arcade game from one of the
[Music]
it uh doesn't seem like an arcade game
from
various games such as like as the
five nights got it hey
are
okay oh
oh no ah
okay hi hello how you doing baby you
look like you've seen better days
baby
yeah yeah okay hello everybody welcome
to five nights at freddy's 6.
this is ah
the worst kept secret it's that this
game came out
all of a sudden actually it was a really
good secret because even i didn't even
i had no tape leaving dead space
three two one
the purpose of this tape is to test
automated response times and reactions
from vintage interactive attractions
following audio stimuli if you are
playing this tape
that means that not only have you been
checking outside at the end of every
shift
as you were instructed to do but also
that you have found something that meets
the criteria of your special obligations
under paragraph four
follow these instructions document
response times
then safely secure the space before
leaving upon sealing the room
you are not to return begin audio prompt
in three two one
audio prompt in three two one
i'm looking
[Applause]
document results no
okay all right audio weird in three
two one
uh
i hate this i hate everything about this
document results
okay all right no i'm looking at you
baby
an audio prompt in three oh so
no one about not
hi that's a yes okay let me check my
backs
hey now it's a new day it's your time to
shine
it's time to take your career into your
own hands
you've saved money your whole life great
now it's time to put all your eggs into
one basket
and take a huge gamble on your future a
gamble that comes with a 100 percent
chance of success in some cases purple
guy what are we talking about
no we're talking about becoming a
fazbear entertainment franchisee
that's right restaurant ownership and
management
something almost anyone can do with a
limited degree of success
sure it's a lot of money to invest but
everyone's doing it
and that means it's safe and lucrative
with your initial investment you'll
receive everything you need to get
started
including a small room some tables and
electricity
but don't forget about the money you had
left over after buying your franchise
package
use it to decorate buy a stage by
attractions and animatronics
and much much more now let's take a look
at a few things that will help you get
started as a fazbear entertainment
franchisee
such as atmosphere making sure your
establishment has an
inviting atmosphere is essential to
bringing in new customers
entertainment having a lot of
entertainment value in your restaurant
will ensure that customers come back
okay bonus revenue point operated games
and attractions can generate additional
revenue during the day
more money in your pocket ready for
reinvestment
health and safety there may be times
when you purchase something of
questionable quality
and we don't blame you cutting corners
is just good business
but there are steps you can take to
ensure you don't get sued for it
and that brings us to liability
being a thrifty shopper is smart but be
aware that buying things on sale comes
with a certain amount of risk
aside from the daily risk of lawsuits
there's also the risk that something
might be hiding inside whatever you just
purchased with that steeply discounted
price tag
of course that would only be a serious
danger if there were something outside
that's been trying to get in for months
now
not confirming to be the case this
concludes the amount of help we are
legally obligated to provide
remember you are now the face of the
newly rebranded
freddy fazbear's pizza that's me today
smile with pride
and let's make some money fazbear
entertainment is not responsible for
disappearance death or dismemberment
oh okay all right okay
okay uh two steps down the restaurant
management you can't log back to
purchase that manufacture
suppliers leave me back to play them
upgrade okay
all right okay
great so it really is a pizzeria tycoon
let's get started
let's see how much you cute little
pieces of [ __ ] you're purchasing your
franchise package
great that should be more than enough
now let's get started
all right on your left are your product
catalogs wow you can unlock more
expensive catalogs by simply purchasing
items for your pizzeria whoa use the
arrows in the bottom right of the item
window to browse the products for each
catalog
wow when you're finished shopping click
the button labeled blueprint mode
to place your items you can switch back
and forth between catalog
mode and blueprint mode as often as you
like before opening your doors to the
public
when you're ready to open your
restaurant for business for the day
click the button labeled finished in
blueprint mode
give it a try and do some shopping wow
wow okay all right it really is oh
look at this look at all this stuff a
fan
hell yeah i'll pick a dock
oh oh bucket bob unavailable but i want
[ __ ] bob [ __ ]
[Music]
stan paper pals i'm gonna buy
them oh hell yeah paper pals
there's a liability risk on that one mr
hugs a little dangerous
thinking oh this is amazing oh yes hang
on
we gotta get the fan that's a that's a
that's a must
i love the duck pod that's like a gotta
have
and then a stage
okay all right well let's place this
garbage just
oh my god oh my god yes
yes yes sponsorship offer ooh
fizz time pop soda have a popping good
time with photon pop
quiz time pop inc is offering to pay for
your advertisement years
except yes yes how do i do that
how do i do that okay i don't have i
don't have an animatronic
all right that's where that'll go ah
fast rating has gone up
no risk absolute play test
[Music]
i got good point i think i got a lot of
points
they were staring at me i don't like
that okay all right well
i got a whole lot of nothing oh
a lot of dick diddly all right well
okay all right good great
restaurant is now officially open yeah
awesome
that doesn't mean your job is finished
however you have a lot of work to do
while patrons eat their pizza in the
other room
from your terminal you have supplies to
buy papers to print
and repairs to make once you've taken
care of all the items on your to-do list
you can log off for the day and get out
of there
money for supplies and repairs comes out
of petty cash
so don't worry about it coming out of
your pocket we've got you covered
the only money you have to worry about
is if you choose to upgrade
any of the equipment in your office now
onto other matters
something to be aware of is that the
ventilation system and your terminal
are pretty loud and may prevent you from
hearing things in adjoining air vents
that won't be a problem if there is
nothing in the vents
however if you feel that something might
be in the vents you have a few tools at
your disposal
to protect yourself you can shut off
your terminal and the ventilation system
at any time
to decrease the amount of attention
you're drawing to yourself
also shining your light directly into a
vent will most likely prevent anything
from jumping out
you also have three tools available from
the terminal itself
there is a motion detector an audio
decoy
and a secondary ventilation unit keep in
mind however
that you can only have one of these
active at any given time
now get to it simply log off when you've
completed your tasks for the day
and you can go get some coffee
oh what did i do i didn't mean to do
that
okay all right okay i'm i'm boned
oh all right well
oh no an ad
okay all right we're fine all right
we're fine i'm gonna stop screaming now
i unclogged toilets i don't even know
why why are those a thing
why why is that a thing uh what am i
running and where
[Music]
i thought it was just gonna be fun and
happy
oh god i hate this i hate this oh i hate
this
that is a long time to print a flyer
okay i guess we're done
do i have to do do i have to do all of
these before i leave is that what you
said i had to do because i don't
really remember
damn it god damn it
okay so wait did you hear that
wait
wait what is that
do you hear
what
what is that i don't know i don't know
anything that's going on here this is
completely different from anything i've
ever seen in any other five nights at
freddy's before
i ain't about this [ __ ] i ain't about to
deal with that [ __ ]
i ain't about to lose my life why does
it take so long to scare
why does it take so long to scan
okay everything's fine uh
uh everything's fine everything's fine i
keep yelling at myself
everything's absolutely fine everything
is 100 fine
okay did i do all my tasks equipment
uh log off i'm out it looks like you're
getting the hang of this
now let's just focus on getting you
through your first week
okay there's a big party here saturday
and you should view that day as your
ultimate test
make it through saturday and you will
have proven yourself
as the successful entrepreneur that we
all know you can be
thank you thank you very much i think
i'm pretty sure
[Music]
congratulations on completing your first
day
however your job isn't over just yet
there is another aspect to your end of
day routine
and that is inspecting and salvaging any
animatronics found in the alley outside
the back door
things are found here quite often and
while we aren't sure why
what we do know is that they can be used
for parts
which can mean a much needed revenue
boost before starting your next day
of course as with everything else in
this line of work
those benefits come with risk the safest
thing to do
is to throw it back outside but then you
get no money for the salvage choose to
keep it
and you run the risk of certain negative
consequences namely
death should the item in question not be
as docile
as it first appeared if you do decide to
try to salvage it
then you must complete the maintenance
checklist
during this testing phase check on the
animatronic frequently
if you feel that it is becoming unstable
use the taser provided to you
you can use it three times without
damaging the hardware
every use over three however will
decrease the item's
salvage value before you is an
animatronic found in the back alley
we are unsure of its origins it is your
job to complete the maintenance
checklist before claiming it as salvage
or if you choose to you can throw it
back into the alley where you found it
and forfeit payment
please make your choice now yeah all
right we'll salvage it
you have chosen to proceed with the
maintenance checklist yeah
remember use your company as you taser
to return the animatronic to a neutral
state if you feel that it's becoming
unstable or aggressive
you can only use it three times before
it begins to damage the animatronic
and decrease its value begin audio
prompt in three
two one
watching you
document results okay no
audio prompt in three two one
[Music]
how are you doing document results
no hey begin audio prompt
in three two one
document results
[Music]
begin audio prompt in three two
one
document results okay
oh why what what's happening begin
audio prompt in three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
oh okay all right all right all right
oh something is loose in my pizzeria
[Music]
what
something's loose in my pizzeria
what does that mean what
i did oh
gumballs swivel hands neon stage lights
sturdy stage mark down wow
condition terrible
oh purchasing a bulky item in this
condition comes with a significant risk
of something undesirable hiding inside
oh by that it's at a discount
[Music]
novelty traffic light happy frog
mr hippo ned ned bear
right ned bear pig patch cadet
candy cadet i'm gonna buy ned
i'm about that bear that bear gonna make
you your your your establishment real
good like
and bear and that bear do good
for you that bear is best bear
all right let's place these bad boys ned
bear you're ned
you're up oh boy wow oh wow ned bear
you know what ned bear i don't feel too
good about this and that bear
bear i gotta gotta admit got a minute
don't feel don't feel too strongly about
this
safety straps
[Music]
i don't know if i want that i don't know
if i want that at all
oh let's play test this bad boy
oh press [ __ ]
[Music]
yes oh another one i was hoping that
it'd be
[Music]
oh my god oh my god that is so funny all
right
all right we're good here we're good
we're good sponsorship
hell yeah what nothing goes down that
can't come up
[Music]
all right advertising perfect let's put
some coin slots on these bad boys
all right coins put some safety straps
yep there we go all right safety strap
[Music]
all right how are you doing oh you're
good you're good all right let's
do this um something's loose in the
establishment oh boy okay so we just got
to order
these [ __ ] and we're good does that look
like a bird beak to you
it looks like a bird beak to me okay i'm
just i'm just knocking these things down
i ain't i ain't waiting for nobody
oh hi oh i'm dead
i didn't even hear a noise there was
nothing
it was just happening
ah what
what where do i pick up i don't even
know
i don't even understand oh lots of way
what
fun oh
oh uh uh
okay you can stop that now
you know that's enough i think that's
enough
you can stop oh boy all right okay
that's enough this is yeah
slow down stop the trend put breaks on
this bad boy
i'm pulling to stop station hey now you
won't stop okay here we go i guess we're
going
it's gonna be lots of fun lots of fun
fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun fun
fun
fun fun fun
ah ooh oh
why does this look like dream daddy why
does it look like dream daddy
okay so anyway that is all the time i
got for this one
i will continue this very soon this is
five nights at freddy's 6 if you want to
call it that
but also it's just a whole grab bag of
weird and scary and awesome so
thank you everybody so much for watching
let me know what you think down in the
comments below
let me know if you've got any more
theories about this game i'll provide a
link to the game in the description
below you can get it off of steam
and thanks everybody so much for
watching buckle up for a wild ride
because this one's gonna be weird and
awesome
so thanks again and as always i will see
you
in the next video bye-bye